hey this is Lauren Zachary with motion
science and today I'm going to share
with you how I gather and use reference
for all my creative projects
[Music]
[Music]
quick disclaimer before getting into the
video after years of working in After
Effects professionally as a motion
designer what I'm about to show you is
the way that has worked for me feel free
to adapt any step to your own projects
and creative needs the first Pitfall to
avoid is to spend too much time browsing
for reference and never starting the
actual project to make sure you're not
endlessly browsing the web for images
set a time constraint the sooner you
start creating the better the second
mistake I notice people make is to only
look at motion design projects that
inspires you to come up with original
ideas you can look for inspiration
outside of your field you can find
inspiration in architectures looking at
buildings various concrete textures and
try and find a story that connects these
elements together you can also look at
nature animals plants trees one of my
personal favorite is to listen to music
I often get inspired by a song or an
insta instrumental that matches the mood
of the piece I'm trying to create you
can also find your own reference through
photography and filming your own footage
all of these elements may help generate
interesting ideas for a story or a new
creative project when it comes to note
taking one of the benefits is to free
clutter from your mind once you start
writing down ideas you can say bye to
creative block I think it's important to
have a system in place that works for
you in this next part I'm going to show
you the apps that I use to organize all
of my creative ideas the first app that
I use is WorkFlowy WorkFlowy is an
amazing way to keep track of lists
creative briefs brainstorm ideas track
deadlines share boards with clients in
an easy and intuitive way I highly
recommend it for a paid alternative you
can use milanode which is equally
awesome in its own way before even
starting a project the first thing I do
is to analyze debris thoroughly look for
keywords in the brief who's the target
audience is there any creative direction
are there things you have to include or
exclude from the project and of course
what are the deliverables once I have an
understanding of the brief I can start
brainstorming in this phase any and all
ideas are valid don't discard anything
yet here's an example of what a
brainstorming session in workflow we can
look like for my last stylecraft
assignment I had to make a title for the
Twilight Zone episode time enough At
Last I gave myself the time limit to
write down keywords for the project as
well as ideas for texture typography
color effects I could use in After
Effects and animation ideas while I
didn't use every one of these effects
and ideas I found it interesting to go
back to whenever I was in Need for
inspiration after brainstorming I will
start Gathering images for visual
inspiration when it comes to visual
reference I like to go on Pinterest for
first then be hands or Instagram you can
also use AI to generate ideas you would
have never thought of before for this
you can use mid-journey or dally too to
make mood boards I love using pure rap
this is a free software that you can get
on pureref.com it's an infinite canvas
where you can add images and notes and
organize during all your inspiration in
one place when it comes to mood boards
you can have one massive board with all
your inspiration or the way I like to
work is to have one board per category
let's say one for type one for texture
one for color and so on in this next
part we're gonna look at a case study of
the Screen Graphics Workshop by motion
science for this case study let's
quickly go over the creative brief then
we'll see how I gathered and used
reference for this project taking it
from an idea to a finished piece here I
had to create three style frames and one
finished Motion test the star map
screens convey complex decoded data on
unknown star systems I had to consider
the mapping elements solar systems and
nebula's measurements and Direction
systems grid systems shapes depth and
blur typography and it had to have a
handheld motion for the tone mood and
style it had to have organic and
circular shapes Moody analog texture and
simple colors two to three tones based
on this creative brief I started
Gathering images for visual inspiration
let's look at my workflow when it comes
to designing mood boards I first went on
Pinterest and created The Screen
Graphics board where I pinned everything
that I found visually interesting this
took some time but I did set myself a
time constraints in the same way I
created this retro board with retro
elements I found to be visually
interesting from there I jumped into
pure rap and dried and dropped the
images from Pinterest that were most
inspiring to me the goal here wasn't to
get inspired by one piece in particular
but to take inspiration from let's say
this piece here with elements from this
board over there and mix it with maybe
some symbols you like on this board here
you can then try and make something that
is truly original and that no one has
seen before if you want to save all the
images you've imported into pure wrap
you can press Ctrl a to select them all
right click save export and save all
images to a designated folder when it
came to designing the wireframe I was
inspired by these two pictures and their
original sci-fi retro layouts for this
left part I was inspired by this grid
and all of the other similar grids with
sharp or rounded Corners I found on
these boards for the style frames you
could see how I gathered and used all
this inspiration to create these final
designs you can see the typography depth
in blur simple colors you can also see
the round circular shapes and UI
elements in the background some Moody
analog texture as well as star maps how
to create this final motion test
[Music]
as you can see from this case study
everything is already made but not by
you I took elements from one board and
another putting them together to create
something new and original to me I
wanted to encourage everyone to use
reference as a starting point then you
can experiment with it and make it yours
to come up with truly original ideas I
also can't stress the importance of
using your notes as a guide throughout
your project I constantly reference them
to make sure I'm still on track with the
creative brief it's easy to get carried
away in your work but always make sure
you have the brief in mind whether it's
your own or clients I hope you liked
this lesson and learned something new
today if you did leave a comment below
until next time this is Lauren zagary
with motion science
foreign
[Music]